you're looking at some of the world's
greatest distance Runners they've broken
records and won numerous medals the
train in eldoret in the rift valley 2
000 meters above sea level
copter got training camp has produced
some of the most successful athletes
ever
life in the camp is simple and Serene
these are athletes who live and breathe
Athletics the exercises are intense but
they do it with so much Poise and Grace
they run train relax and then repeat
it's amazing to watch
Elliott is a world's fastest male
marathon runner
this has been his home for the last 17
years
but he's worried about the sport Kenya
is grappling with a serious doping
problem dozens of athletes have been
banned for illegal drug offenses in the
last few years I think the undisturbing
measures are really enough if they
change their tactics from giving more
education to more testing but if you
give education on on many things and you
are not testing then it's a it's it's
it's like we are doing nothing but it's
good to to get knowledge
but it's good also to be practical Faith
keep your gun trains alongside kipchoge
the man's Champion she recently broke
two World Records in a week
she's also worried about doping sexual
exploitation and increasing violence
against women athletes I can say it's
all about education it's all about
education
if we have our mentors matter mentors to
Mentor the young girls and young women I
hope we will stronger we will be as
strong as women
these are issues they often talk about
and they say they're determined to
inspire and nurture young talent to
restore the reputation of the region of
Champions Catherine zoy Al Jazeera
captain